batta
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur
zapater avec whaou
ouais on m'a dit les frites c'est bien
le gars qui ont aujourd'hui la can
alors
à
[Applaudissements]
il est vrai qu'un truc hein une truite
c'est une truite
ça c'est une truite doucement
j'aurai avec une frite des dents c'est
une troupe belge
buffon des lâchers de truites votre
temps en temps paraît
pourtant votre bonhomme c'est plutôt des
lâches et her way
[Applaudissements]
bref
ils croient pas
c'est donc la troisième encore une
incroyable et en ligne
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que je pêche
guidon
a laissé payer d'ibol les frites
[Musique]
magie quand on les connaît ouais ouais
j'ai ma femme elle est en vacances alors
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi un
fait rentrer à moi
et puis bonne pêche
je rigolais tout à l'heure quand je met
une frite sur l'association après j'ai
rigolé quand j'ai vu sortir la truite
j'ai pu rigoler car ça y est c'est parti
ce parti debout
elle est repartie en dessous c'est pas
vrai
oula
non non non non ce n'est pas crochet là
c'est très drôle parce que c'est mais
c'est très gros c'est peut-être une très
grosse truite
je voulais sortir
je vais avoir besoin de sortir ou un
gros ou là la
méchante et un gros ah ouais c'est un
gros morceau là c'est une grosse truite
amont avant abba c'est quoi ça
c'est un gars qui accrochait détruites
aaa à l'épaule ça va la caméra cachée
[Rires]
[Musique]